WELCOME TO "CONNECT THE WORLD."
I'M LINDA KINKADE SITTING IN FOR
BECKY ANDERSON.
WE START THIS HOUR WITH CNN'S
UNPRECEDENTED ACCESS TO
UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT ON THE FRONT
LINES ON EASTERN UKRAINE.
RUSSIA HAS AMASSED AN ADDITIONAL
50,000 TROOPS.
MOST OF THEM ON RUSSIAN'S
WESTERN BORDER.
THE REST IN CRIMEA WITH 31,000
TROOPS ALREADY DEPLOYED.
THAT'S THE MOST RUSSIAN TROOPS
IN THE AREA SINCE RUSSIA IN
2014.
IN FIGHTING THAT KILLED 14,000
PEOPLE.
THE LATEST TROOP BUILD UP
LEADING TO FEARS OF ANOTHER
RUSSIAN INVASION AND AN APPEAL
FROM UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT FOR
HELP FROM THE UNITED STATES.
MATTHEW CHANCE IS JOINING ME
WITH DETAILS.
THE FRONT LINE, GOOD TO HAVE YOU
WITH US.
INCREDIBLE ACCESS.
YOU GOT THERE BECAUSE WE KNOW
THIS WAR HAS BEEN SIMMERING AWAY
SINCE 2015.
BUT FROM WHAT WE'RE SEEING, THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT CALLING IT THE
BIGGEST APPOINTMENT OF RUSSIAN
TROOPS ON THE GROUND THERE IN
SEVEN YEARS.
EXPLAIN WHAT YOU WITNESSED ON
THE FRONT LINE.
>> Reporter: THERE'S BUILD UP OF
FORCES ACROSS THE BORDER, WHICH
UKRAINE SAYS IS MORE THAN 50,000
PERSONNEL IN RECENT WEEKS.
IT WAS INCREDIBLE TO BE TOURING
THE TRENCHES ON THE LIFRONT LIN
OF UKRAINE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
COUNTRY, WE SPOKE ABOUT HOW THE
TROOPS ARE HOLDING UP.
WE SPOKE ABOUT WHAT RUSSIA MIGHT
BE UP TO.
WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT WHAT THE
UNITED STATES AND ITS ALLIES CAN
DO TO TRY TO BRING THIS CONFLICT
TO AN END.
A SIMMERING CONFLICT, ONCE AGAIN
THE FOCUS OF U.S. CONCERN.
AS TENSIONS WITH RUSSIA RATCHET
HIGHER, CNN GAINED THIS
UNPRECEDENTED ACCESS TO THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT.
FLYING WITH HIM FAST AND LOW TO
AVOID GROUND FIRE.
>> IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME NOW.
IT'S BEEN SEVEN YEARS.
>> YES.
>> HOW ARE THE SOLDIERS HOLDING
UP?
>> THEY CAME IN AND IT'S LONGER
THAN THE SECOND WORLD WAR.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
>> Reporter: LONGER THAN THE
SECOND, BUT WITH ITS COMPLEX
WORK OF DANK, MUDDY TRENCHES,
THIS SO-CALLED LINE OF CONTACT
IN SOME PLACES JUST A FEW DOZEN
YARDS FROM THE ENEMY LOOKS MORE
LIKE THE FIRST WORLD WAR.
WE HAVE ENTERED THIS WORLD OF
TRENCHES THAT HAVE BEEN DUG
ALONG THE FRONT LINE.
I TELL YOU, I MEAN, IT'S LIKE
BEING THROWN BACK TO THE EARLY
20th CENTURY AND THE GREAT WAR.
I HAVE NOT SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS IN MODERN WARFARE.
BUT THIS IS MODERN.
REALITY OF CONFRONTATION WITH
MOSCOW AND ITS PROXIES.
IS THERE A CHANCE THAT THE
RUSSIANS COULD BE PLANNING AN
INVASION?
>> OF COURSE.
WE KNOW IT.
WE KNOW IT CAN BE.
EACH DAY IT CAN BE.
SO THEY ARE READY.
AND WE ARE ALSO READY.
BECAUSE WE ARE ON OUR LAND AND
OUR TERRITORY.
>> THIS IS WHY UKRAINE, THE U.S.
AND THE WESTERN ALLIES ARE SO
ALARMED.
AMID GROWING TENSIONS, THE
DRAMATIC BUILD-UP OF RUSSIAN
FORCES NEAR THE UKRAINIAN BORDER
AND IN CHRRIMEA.
CELL PHONE FOOTAGE EMERGED.
AND OF MILITARY HARDWARE BEING
TRANSPORTED BY RAIL TOWARDS THE
BORDER.
UKRAINIAN MILITARY OFFICIALS
TELL CNN THEY ESTIMATE MORE THAN
50,000 RUSSIAN TROOPS ARE
AMASSING.
THEY SAY IT'S JUST AN EXERCISE
SHS NOT A THREAT.
BUT BACK AT THE LINE OF CONTACT,
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN A DEADLY UP
SURGE IN SNIPER FIRE.
MORE THAN 20 SOLDIERS KILLED,
SAY UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS, SO FAR
THIS YEAR.
OUT HERE, EVEN THE PRESIDENT
RUNS THE GAUNTLET.
>> COME ON, LET'S GO.
>> SO WE'RE VERY CLOSE NOW,
AREN'T WE, TO THE SEPARATISTS.
THAT WAS AMAZING.
WE HAVE COME SO CLOSE NOW TO THE
FRONT LINE BETWEEN UKRAINIAN
FORCES AND THE RUSSIAN-BACKED
SEPARATISTS THAT THE PRESIDENT
AND I HAD TO RUN BETWEEN THE
OPEN GROUND TO GET TO THIS COVER
BECAUSE THE SITUATION IS SO
VOLATILE, SO POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS HERE.
ELECTED TWO YEARS AGO ON A
PROMISE OF ENDING THIS CONFLICT,
SOMETHING HAS FAILED TO ACHIEVE,
THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE RISKS
THESE HOT SPOTS, AS HE CALLS
THEM, TO SHOW THESE FROT LINE
SOLDIERS THEY HAVE POLITICAL
SUPPORT.
WHAT UKRAINE REALLY NEEDS, HE
SAYS S MOREN ASSISTANCE FROM
WASHINGTON.
MORE WEAPONS, MORE MONEY,
CRUCIALLY MORE BACKING TO B JOIN
NATO, THE WESTERN MILITARY
ALLIANCE.
SUPPORTIVE WORDS FROM PRESIDENT
BIDEN ARE SIMPLY NO LONGER
ENOUGH.
>> UKRAINE NEED MORE THAN WORDS.
>> CAN I ASK A FOLLOW-UP ON
THAT.
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT IF UKRAINE
WERE TO BE GIVEN THAT, THAT
MIGHT MAKE THE CONFLICT IN THIS
COUNTRY EVEN WORSE.
IT WOULD INFURIATE.
>> I CAN ANSWER YOU, MAYBE YOU
ARE RIGHT, BUT WHAT NOW DID YOU
HEAR WHAT OUR PEOPLE DO HERE,
THEY FIGHT.
SO WHAT CAN BE IN THE FUTURE, WE
DECIDE.
WHERE TO BE OR NOT TO BE.
>> Reporter: THAT IS THE
QUESTION.
OR RATHER HOW MUCH U.S. SUPPORT
CAN THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT NOW
EXPECT IN THE RUNNING DRAMA
BEING PLAYED OUT IN THIS THEATER
OF WAR.
THE PROSPECT MOVING CLOSER TO
NATO MEMBERSHIP IS SOMETHING THE
RUSSIANS MADE CLEAR THAT THEY
ARE OPPOSED TO RECENTLY.
THE FOREIGN MINISTRY SPOKESWOMAN
SAYING THAT EVEN POTENTIAL
MEMBERSHIP OF NATO FOR UKRAINE
COULD HAVE IRREVERSIBLE
CONSEQUENCES FOR UKRAINE'S
STATE.
THAT'S NOT A VAIL THREAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS.
>> I OBJECT INCREDIBLE THERE ON
THE FRONT LINE UP CLOSE.
AND THERE'S THIS FIGHTING PICKED
UP LAST MONTH, ALREADY WE KNOW
NINE SOLDIERS HAVE DIED.
JUST GIVE US A SENSE OF HOW THE
KREMLIN IS TRYING TO JUSTIFY
THIS.
>> Reporter: YEAH, 20 SOLDIERS,
FROM WHAT I HAVE BEEN TOLD, AT
LEAST THIS YEAR ALONE BECAUSE OF
THE UP SURGE IN VIOLENCE ALONG
THE FRONT LINES, IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE KREMLIN ARE DOING, IT'S
AS USUAL PRETTY OPAQUE.
WHAT THEY SAY IS THAT THESE ARE
REGULAR MILITARY EXERCISES.
THESE AREN'T INTENDED TO
THREATEN ANYONE AND THEY ARE NOT
A PRECURSOR FOR MILITARY ACTION.
UKRAINE FEELS THREATENED AND
THERE'S A BIG CONCERN AMONGST
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY THAT
SOMETHING MORE OMINOUS MAY SORT
OF TAKE PLACE.
NOW WHAT'S HAPPENING, DO THEY
HAVE A PLAN, SOMETIMES THE
RUSSIANS USE MILITARY ADVENTURES
TO DISTRACT FROM PROBLEMS
DOMESTICALLY AT HOME AND
CERTAINLY A LOT OF PROBLEMS AT
HOME IN RUSSIA.
THEY ALSO MAY BE SENDING A
MESSAGE TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
TENSIONS ARE HIGH.
THIS IS BEEN SANCTIONS OVER
ALLEGATIONS OF HACKING.
IT WAS ONLY A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
JOE BIDEN CALLED THE RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT THE KILLER.
HE ABSOLUTELY HATED THAT.
THIS COULD BE A TEST OF THE
RESOLVE F YOU LIKE, OF THE NEW
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO SEE WHAT
THEY WILL DO.
>> WE CERTAIN LY WILL WAIT AND
SEE WHAT RESPONSE THERE IS IF
ANY AT THI